[Musica]
bella a tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a
questo nuovo video io sono fatti j
oggi iniziamo una nuova serie bugs bunny
loss in time per playstation 1 è stata
una delle serie più votati in assoluto
sul sondaggio della pagina di facebook
l'avete votato in tantissimi perché
credo che come me da piccoli ci giocava
te io ci giocavo un casino da piccolo
l'itf ha vj nerd su bugs bunny allora
direi che possiamo iniziare balconi
rossi time e richiede un blocco di
memoria libero che continua accesso alla
memory card una partita vuota ci siamo
siamo per tornare indietro nel tempo a
quando io portavo ancora il tuo anno
link
beh per alcuni giochi horror dovrei
ancora portarlo il pannolino però
lasciamo perdere
bene ci siamo eccomi qua ismo bridge
appello da parte che non ci vediamo
aspetto minuto se questa nostra miglia
ha fatto alpinismo bt smobilita dal
bouquet di andare a destra e poi guarda
le dimensioni di quel distributore di
succo di carote certo esattamente così è
un distributore di succo di carota mai
convinto ok ok perfetto all'inizio non
me lo ricordavo così ragazzi mi
ricordavo che si partiva tipo anche e ci
stiamo per arrivare diano
allora è per chi non ha mai giocato a
bugs bunny lost in time ovvero per chi
non ha mai avuto un'infanzia è
praticamente il gioco si suddivide in
ere la prima e da nessuna parte ovvero
non è un'era ma semplicemente un luogo
dove ci sarà il tutorial e poi man mano
che sbloccheremo che raccoglieremo delle
sveglie delle carote d'oro che adesso
vedrete che cosa sono
ci sbloccheremo delle nuove ere che sono
bloccate questa richiede una sveglia
ovvero e quella iniziale che sono
ricordo male l'età della pietra
poi c'è questa qui poi ci sono tutte le
altre ovviamente fino ad arrivare a
quella finale che non mi sono neanche
quale che sono comunque tutte epoche
diverse tipo c'è il medioevo ce n'era
dei pirati
vabbè un casino comunque direi di
iniziare da nessuna parte vai questo qua
è il regno di merlino ragazzo
e una zona abbastanza cupa nowhere nel
quale è perfetto accidempoli mi trovo
[Musica]
forse la persona che vive in questo loco
mi può dire dove sono e come evitare di
restarci più a lungo il tratto come stai
il mio nome a merlino e sono un mago
sì sul serio umago abbiamo fammi vedere
una magia e ti prego ti prego
ma certo qualsiasi cosa per compiacere
un ospite
[Musica]
[Risate]
niente male come trucco merlino cicinho
tu lo sai fare questo
[Musica]
così almeno avrà un hobby ma io mi sento
colpo lontano dal mio habitat naturale
mi spiace interrompere questa
dimostrazione spettacolo ma saprebbe
dirmi dove mi trovo
sembra che tutto sia perduto nel tempo
mio caro qui non siamo in nessun luogo
in nessun luogo e sa dirmi come faccio
per tornare in un qualche luogo
certo che lo so devi andare da un'epoca
un'altra e trovare simboli come questo
esse ti daranno accesso a nuovi luoghi e
ti porteranno progressivamente al tempo
presente
allora fai attenzione coniglio
raccogli 10 di questi oggetti per
ottenere un simbolo orologio basta basta
così per ora
ciao ci vediamo averlo no ci vediamo
merlo è qualcosa di epico nome l'hanno
dimenticato sì lo dice sempre bug babele
raga allora l'inizio quello che state
per vedere adesso
praticamente il tutorial vi spiega come
giocare io questo primo pezzo lo
salterei quindi direi di fare un taglio
perché è tanto vi spiega soltanto i
comandi e non c'è nulla di nuovo si
spiega soltanto come si gioca quindi
raga direi di tagliare e ci vediamo
direttamente a quanto finito tutorial
ok raga direi che possiamo iniziare
veramente a giocare a bugs bunny
prendiamo la macchina del tempo e
andiamo alla prima era
ho già preso la sveglia perché 10 carote
d'oro brevemente sono una sveglia la
prima era si sbloccava ad una sveglia
sola quindi dovrebbe hanno ascoltata che
questa l'età della pietra ci siamo ok
ragazzi perfetto daga la musica di bugs
bunny mio dio e 10 anni che non la sento
mamma viene nostalgia si parlò come un
nerd non me ne frega un cazzo perché me
ne ricordo se cosa mi divertivo vabbè
coniglio in arrivo sveglia a zero su 9
carota d'oro a zero su 22 ok primo
livello primo livello in assoluto di
bugs bunny lost in time parte adesso c'è
un filmatino all'inizio mi pare se
perfetto gesto stronzo domenico nome si
chiama però mi è sempre stato sul culo
anche nel cartone animato quando ero
piccolo guardavo un amico ok
ok perfetta ci siamo qua devo spingere
sta roba che non mi ricordo che cosa fa
eh sì mi pare ci sia una carota d'oro vi
sia perfetto ok la prima l'ho trovata
allora raga premetto che l'età della
pietra non era il mio livello preferito
diciamo da quando ero piccolo intanto
faccio un incudine ma è già caduta ok
perfetto
i sei ok si sono bene prima seconda
carota d'oro seconda siamo già due
dicevo non era uno dei miei livelli
preferiti di quando ero piccolo però
c'è il mio preferito mi pare che fosse
quello dei pirati che comunque non è
neanche tanto lontano è però quello
dell'età della pietra non era uno dei
miei preferiti ma comunque sono tutti
epici raga per chi l'ha giocato se lo
ricorderà sono uno più epico dell'altro
allora ecco c'è la prima sveglia intanto
nave vista di pichichi ok bene la prima
sveglia ce l'abbiamo già
non mi ricordo sinceramente il i versi
va bene sono mi ricordi livelli perché
sono dieci anni che non ci gioco però
che forse devo andare da giù come faccia
arrivarci dai che chavez è perfetto è lì
dietro mi ricordo che se non a sveglia
alcune cose mi ricordo
raga non so se vi capita se lo stesso
per voi per quelli che ci giocavano ma
io tipo dei flashback nel senso che ci
siano cose che mi ricordo intanto comi
sono spiattellato in una maniera assurda
ci sono cose che mi ricordo e cose che
non mi ricordo c'è tipo ok perfetto non
mi ricordo questo livello in generale
però per farvi un esempio vi ricordavo
che qui dietro c'era una sveglia cioè
come se avessi come se avessi dei
flashback praticamente eh sì perché sono
veramente troppi anni che non ci gioco
comunque ok ci siamo
dobbiamo tornare indietro mamma mia che
culo ok
qua c'è merlino non salvo la partita che
tanto siamo solo emulatore mi dovrei
riuscire a salvare con il tasto f1
ok no ok ci sono lo stimato per il bel
mamma mia che mamma mia che bravo che
bratu non riesco a prenderlo per oro
ok ce l'ho fatta bene siamo 8 carote
d'oro appena iniziato a giocare già
amico
anche qui dietro ce n'è uno a me lo
ricordo anno c'è una sedia perfetto ok
fantastico c'è un'altra roba qui dietro
ok
e siamo a 9 ok come primo livello sta
andando benissimo merda come non detto
come non detto mi se tu puoi disagio
orario a giocare col joystick perché di
solito quando gioco sono tipo così ma
adesso sono costretto a stare un
chilometro indietro perché ciò joystick
giustamente non è che non ha senso che
io rimanga così guidare dei calci
all'albero si questo me lo ricordavo
c'è tipo cosa è quello cos'è perché c'è
un'ombra cazzo ok ok non me lo ricordavo
che c'erano l'incudine c'è sì l'avevo
vista prima ma non mi ricordavo che
cadevano
ok perfetto ok piovono in cui di mira e
un giorno mi fa passare grazie perfetto
fatemi salvare io ne approfitto dato che
siamo sulle muratore salvo subito
ok ci siamo raganello già il calciatore
se lo vedete in basso a destra
e qui sotto ok checkpoint perfetto devo
riuscire ad arrivare dall'altra parte
saltandolo di sulla testa ok mi ricordo
un buongiorno sono bugs bunny ok mi sta
inseguendo raga non mi ricordo come si
fa
forse devo tempo saltarli sulla testa
una roba del genere ok merda mi ha preso
bene però devo riuscire a r101 siamo
apre abbiamo preso anche una sveglia
perfetto
ok devo fare tipo lo slalom tra i
dinosauri
fatemi salvare ok ok perfetto
pensiamo ci siamo ci siamo ci siamo ci
siamo mamma mia mamma lo fanno lo
facciamo così veloce nemmeno da piccolo
ok perfetto ci siamo 14 carote d'oro ok
siamo quante suoi e quanti soldi c'erano
mi pare 9 una roba del genere avevo
letto 9 svegli e 22 carote
siamo a 14 carote quindi non le devo
raccogliere tutte però diciamo più ne
raccoglie più livelli ti sblocchi quindi
è meglio che ne raccolgo il più
possibile ok in questo punto qui non mi
ricordo sinceramente non mi ricordo
ancora uno di questi perfetto no
maledetto strana in ha preso qualche
bastardo perfetto ho vinto io
altra carota d'oro ok
17 18 e un'altra sveglia mamma mia che
sto raccogliendo tutto incredibile ok
siamo no perfetto non devo andare di qua
ce n'è un'altra ala sud
ok come ci arrivo al sud evo devo
catapultarmi giu perfetto
bene allora torniamo indietro
sinceramente mi pare che
ok l'incudine l'ho saltata mi pare che
devo mi basta anche solo il primo
livello per poter sbloccare le altre ere
ok perché c'è uno pterodattilo che ha
tentato di prendermi ok ragazzi sono di
nuovo per non svegliare lo pterodattilo
devo fare piano
ok siamo un'altra sveglia si che poi
faccio tanto piano e poi urlo quando
prendo le sveglie ok i pissi in teoria
ne avrebbe già dovuto mangiare vivo ma
non fa niente dettagli allora c'è
un'altra sveglia da gioco prima che se
prima che ci arrivo faccio che tagliare
perché ci metto secoli dai dai dai dai
dai brutto stronzo 88 perfetto ci sono
ragazzi sono ok
vai se abbiamo vinto
ok ho raccolto tipo una ventina di
carote 8 sveglie quindi ottimo quasi
tutte praticamente mai lasciato degli
oggetti alle tue spalle mai lasciato
degli uffici e le due spalle ricordarsi
le cose raga è fantastico indovina chi
serve una spintarella ok ha sbloccato
perfetto sbloccando il primo ho
sbloccato il primo livello del dell'era
dei pirati soul village posizione si
merlo
ok
grazie merla gemello si ok ho salvato la
partita allora 8 su 9 19 su 22 quindi il
risultato praticamente ottimo e non so
se ho sbloccato già la nuova era ma non
mi pare
devo fare prima l'altro livello allora
facciamo anche questo così già nel
prossimo episodio sono già nell'era dei
pirati indovina chi serve una
spintarella ok mi pare che sia già il
boss finale si perfetto perché
praticamente le aeree sono tanti livelli
e in più alla fine c'è il boss finale
per ogni era questo qui è il boss della
prima era appunto che non mi ricordo
come si chiama
ok fantastico
scommetto che ti arriva dietro al
permettono
[Musica]
ok si sia paragrafetto siamo partiti
sfida contro il primo boss già il primo
episodio non me lo ricordavo perché
dicevo adesso ne approfitto per
spiegarlo nel frattempo che mi rincorre
praticamente i livelli di bugs bunny
sono che tu puoi fare quanti livelli
decidi di fare quando ti sblocchi la
sfida del boss finale puoi decidere di
farla c'erano devi completati per forza
a tutti ecco diciamo questo ok
si mise di tetto sono riuscito a
colpirlo già una volta perché mi ricordo
come si fa
ok perfetto ci sono forse mi ha visto
non mi ha visto perfetto ci siamo e
siamo già due ragazze manca no merda non
un caso che mila di merda perfetto
ok la fede non colpire non soltanto fino
a volte poi ci siamo
merda mi ha preso ok ok ok ok perfetto
per me raga epico e fantastico ok
perfetto non vi dico quali sono i boss
degli altri livelli perché se non ve li
ricordate lascio che sia una sorpresa
però tanto si intuisce perché del boss
si vede sempre all'inizio di ogni era
comunque ce l'abbiamo fatta abbiamo
battuto il primo boss che appunto è
facile perché essendo prima è una
cavolata assurda e poi ci siamo abbiamo
finito l'età della pietra hanno
veramente no perché ci sono degli altri
livelli che poi andrò a fare sicuramente
però le prossime episodi iniziano già le
rari pirati così almeno ok c'è merlo
fantastico perfetto hai completato
questo livello
vedete ci sono tipo 80 sveglia per
sbloccarlo devo andare nelle altre ere
raccogliere svegli e poi tornare qui più
avanti se voglio farli e vabbè sono
altre cose comunque che il più avanti
magari le farò comunque era che abbiamo
sbloccato l'era dei pirati direi di
andare ma prima di
a cominciarla e si trova esattamente non
mi ricordo dove ecco il tempo di pirati
perfetto il boss finale di ogni livello
non è detto all'inizio infatti penso che
partiranno filmato no a siffatte quando
entrò nel primo livello vabbè la musica
assurda
me la ricordo armato anna che bello
miglio me lo ricordo ancora va beh direi
che posso dire cosa e questo non mi
ricordo non è l'abilità asi l'abilità
del super salto che ci si sblocca più
avanti ok ok essi poi c'è tipo anche la
bocca del teschio che si apre su un
livello segreto all'interno
vabbè dai prossimo livello e che succede
amico io vi dico soltanto che è l'era
dei pirati forse la mia preferita è già
dal prossimo episodio la posso fare dire
che per ora posso chiudere qui se mi è
piaciuto il video come al solito
lasciato un commento mi piace anche la
pagina di facebook e come in ogni video
trovate nella descrizione se non siete
ancora iscritti iscrivetevi e noi ci
vediamo al prossimo video bella ragazzi